now we're really happy we have arkansas
senator tom cotton with us tonight
senator
now the issue of crime
and our under incarceration problem have
been
really big on your uh your list to
address in the u.s senate
what do you make of what we're seeing
tonight with the facts as we know them
tonight
well it's another horrifying string of
crimes in memphis the people of memphis
deserve much better than what they've
gotten from their city government
in just the last few days you've seen
these crimes that's reflective of crime
going back to memphis for a long time
it's reflected of crime in big cities
across america i'm praying right now
that law enforcement in memphis or if
this killer has crossed the mississippi
river and arkansas is able to swiftly
apprehend him
but as you point out we got to this
point in part because of failures of the
left across america to treat criminals
as the criminals they are we do not have
an over-incarceration problem in this
country as the left says even as some
republicans say
half of all violent crimes go unsolved
four-fifths out of all property crimes
go and solve tell their victims that we
have an over-incarceration problem in
this country
killers like the one we see tonight are
depraved sociopaths they need to be
locked up or they need to be executed
that's the way to keep our citizens safe
from these criminals
now senator speaker pelosi today
kind of revealed what her goal is after
the midterms if the democrats managed to
stay in power watch this
we just passed
the assault weapon ban in the house of
representatives if we just went two more
senators who share our view in this next
election will be able to pull back
that filibuster and pass the background
check legislation and again
the assault weapon ban and make the
world safer senator
that's what's going to happen if people
keep voting for democrats innocent
americans will be deprived of their
ability and of their weapon of choice to
use for self-defense
and more depraved criminals will be
released onto the streets that's what
happened here tonight this man should be
behind bars he was let out in two years
instead of three three is a joke for a
sentence in the in the first place
think about what nancy pelosi is saying
democrats across the country have
eliminated the bail system they've
shortened prison sentences they've
eliminated the death penalty they
sympathize with criminals more than
their victims and then when you see
crime rampages like we've seen in
memphis in the last few days black
cities and that you've seen in
philadelphia what's the democrats
solution is to take away your right as a
law abiding citizen to defend yourself
and your family look at john fetterman
the democratic nominee for senate in
pennsylvania he said if he had a magic
wand and he could just change one thing
it wouldn't be the cost of gasoline it
wouldn't be the price of your groceries
it wouldn't be the opioid crisis we have
in this country if john fetterman had a
magic wand the one thing he would do is
eliminate long prison sentences for
murderers and john fetterman is not an
outlier he may be a radical but he is
entirely representative of the radical
left in america today that has unleashed
a crime wave across this country you saw
in that clip what nancy pelosi says her
answer to be which is disarming
law-abiding citizens that's why every
one of your viewers should go out and
vote republican in two months to make
sure that we can protect our fellow
citizens from these depraved criminals
and senator cotton another point that we
have to raise here is that
i i think the the injection of race into
the criticism of the police which we saw
going back to al sharpton echoed by eric
holder in 2014
uh where it was the first instinct of
theirs was to say
it's racial if someone's arrested it's
racial if someone is manhandled it's
racist
that's also i think compromise policing
across the country because you talk to
the police they're afraid they're afraid
to do anything
lest they be called racist for
arresting someone who's not cooperative
it's very difficult to be a police
officer in this environment
it's incredibly challenging to be police
today laura i talked to police officers
all across the country and they worry
very much that mayors or county
executives or governors will not support
them when in the heat of the moment they
have to use deadly force they want
accountability for anyone who acts
inappropriately but they don't want
politicians jumping to conclusions and
throwing them under the bus we should
back the men and women in blue they are
the only thing that stand between you
and your family and these criminals like
you see tonight in this rampage across
the city of memphis and in fact the
people who are most harmed by this crime
wave are likely to be minorities memphis
is a majority african-american city look
at what they've had to deal with not
just in the last few days but in months
and years of rising crime the same is
the case in so many cities across
america the democratic left has failed
african americans where crime is rising
in their neighborhoods that man that
killed eliza fletcher was apparently
terrorizing his own community the
apartment building he lived in where
were the police officers black white
latino or any other race to protect
those citizens they deserve better from
their elected leaders yeah meanwhile we
have all these consent decrees that the
justice department still has an effect
on police departments across the country
i'm not saying there doesn't need to be
any reforms i'm sure their
reforms are necessary in some cases but
the findings of implicit bias and
policing those are those are too readily
found with very little uh evidence and
uh senator uh
back to the eric holder point can i like
to read this quote just so people know
what i'm talking about back in 2013 he
said
too many people go to too many prisons
for far too long for no good law
enforcement reason we need to ensure
that incarceration is used to punish
deter and rehabilitate not merely to
warehouse
and
forget well
your final reaction to that senator
given the news tonight
well i think most citizens in memphis
wish that this killer had spent more
than just a few years in jail for his
crimes where liza fletcher and her
family wish that her killer had spent
more time in jail than we did for his
heinous crimes prison is there not only
to punish and to deter but also to
incapacitate as you suggested some
people simply need to be locked up to
keep this country safe and if they're
depraved murderers they need to be
executed something the byte
administration has refused to do from
the day they took office even though
they're still federal prisoners sitting
on death row something that the
democratic left and left-wing legal
activists have tried to stop states like
arkansas for doing for decades now
people keep voting democrat this is what
they're going to get sadly more crime
and
you know more depravity across the
country senator thank you tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else